hi this is Nia
today I'm gonna make shepherd's pie this
is actually my second time making the
shepherd's pie we'll see how it turns
out
first we're gonna heat the oven and 400
Fahrenheit
let me see make sure there's nothing in
here okay why do you like to respond Oh
cuz you like it okay so now it's warming
up and next step we need potatoes we
have to peel the potato skin and we will
use five potatoes today I don't like
killing the potato skin because I'm
afraid I'll cut my finger maybe Evan
should do all the preparation next time
no I don't know maybe there is if you
know please let me know that's why I say
I don't like cutting the skin so we will
need ground beef onion and carrots
potatoes
I'm gonna add some mushrooms and corn
and peas oh yeah that's it okay now I
have to peel the carrot skin okay now
I'm gonna cut the potatoes and put in
this pot I'm gonna cut the potato in in
a small cube this big so I have to boil
the potatoes okay put it on high heat
and add some salt to to the potato
it gives flavor to the potato or next
thing is we have to cut the carrots how
I cut the carrot I sliced in to each
quarter
and then and then slice into small cube
cubes to tiny cubes it doesn't take long
to make the chakra spike just all the
preparation and cutting takes longer I
pre cut the onion last night it's about
one about one whole onion and then to
smoke like dice small very tiny oh yeah
I was crying so hard cutting this onions
I'm gonna use vegetable oil vegetable
oil so next I'm gonna cut up some
mushrooms how how do you wash the
mushrooms you don't suck the wash
mushroom in the in the water
you have to use a wet towel paper towel
to wipe it down that's what I've been
taught in school I don't remember the
reason you don't have to add my mushroom
to the shepherd's pie but we like
mushrooms especially this guy behind a
camera right now
you need to have mushrooms and
shepherd's pie the oven is ready but I'm
not ready
so I'm gonna put the onions in here let
it suck say a little bit about I'll be
about five minutes let the onion turn
brown caramelized onions
also the carrots
nice fallacy mushrooms
if you like the buttery taste you can
add butter instead of vegetable oil I
think the potato is almost ready oh no
actually I'm wrong it's not very good to
know whether the potatoes are ready or
not you can use a fork to cook the
potatoes or but me I use my finger to
touch the potatoes maybe one more minute
and we will add the ground beef usually
you can use one pound if you want to use
two pounds then you've mutt you might
need more cringe pushdowns either ground
beef makes make sure it fits love Mickey
Lolich lumps here and there I think this
is pretty good I'm gonna add some salt
pepper rosemary and thyme sauce for ve
to taste
st. as pepper to taste to
we rosemary you can maybe like to pinch
like like this
I sang to pinch
this system
I'll do the tasty
that's good enough okay next we have to
transfer the meat into this pan as you
know what what's easier just put them
everything in here I don't want to you
see
Hevy I always press it down okay it's
nice and even now let's brush potato
time I hope I have enough much potato
it doesn't have to be perfect because
I'm not serving this at a restaurant I'm
only serving it to my husband it's not
perfect you have to press down the
mashed potato especially in the corner
area oh no I'm afraid I might not have
enough
you have it here a little bit here
just enough okay so this is done I'm
gonna let it bake for maybe 15 minutes
and then I'm gonna add some cheese just
on one side of the the best potato
the oven has already preset for 400
Fahrenheit and I'm gonna set for 15
minutes and then let it bake okay in the
meantime I'm gonna clean it up or it may
be Elif you claim you know the the
shepherd's pie is ready but remember I
said I'm gonna put some cheese on it
half of it to put cheese on half of the
shepherd's pie so let's see hmm
steamy hot this is optional if you don't
want the if you don't want to sprinkle
with cheese bake it for 20 minutes let
it sit for 25 minutes and you're ready
to surf if you want to add cheese then
bake it for 15 minutes add the cheese
and bake it for another 2 5 minutes
we're gonna have cheese on half of the
shepherd's pie just sprinkle it if you
want to add a lot of cheats have been
really like the cheese so we're gonna
add more you can use cheddar cheese I
use the mix musher Ella
cheddar cheese like we got this from
whole food it's half
then going it's gonna go back to the
oven bake for another five minutes timer
set for five minutes
okay that's it and then after it's done
stick it up set let it sit for 25
minutes and it's ready to serve and then
we'll let you know how it tastes however
we'll let you know how it tastes like
okay so five minutes over that's ready
I'm gonna take it up Oh first turn off
the oven for Tots turn
and I see looks like this so I'm gonna
gonna let it sit for 25 minutes and then
we will do the tasting while waiting for
the shepherd's pie I make some smoothies
if you want to learn how to make the
smoothies comment below so the
shepherd's pie it's done we had like I
said probably over 25 minutes okay
looks like this you could made for this
side or even both sides you can add
gravy to it
I have gravy made already made from from
the day before
so actually you know I'm gonna heat up
the gravy a little bit if you want to
learn how to make the gravy please leave
the comment below I always like to cover
the stuff before I microwave for hours a
lot of cleanup to do after
he did up for 30 seconds okay it's ready
oh it's hot okay okay
steer gravy on the top are you gonna
come over and try brochure are you
serious just can you stand up a little
bit more oh man the red wine sauce
mm-hmm the red wine makes you thank you
for watching this video if you liked the
video and you liked the recipe for the
shepherd's pie please like the video and
comment below and subscribe enjoy bye
oh no let's just turn everything up
okay timer if I'm in it no oh my god
what am i doing
sometimes I don't understand this oven
heaven stop it yeah yeah but I don't
have to like pins
maybe you should go shopping what do you
think can you give me one more carrots
from the fridge
if you want some believe in your inbox
every week to keep you motivated check
out the link below to join my newsletter